i didn't realize i was on skid row yes
you're on skid row
welcome to scooter
yes the infamous skid row yes i've heard
of it
yeah you're the heart of it right now
that i've yeah it's pretty
it's pretty uh hardcore yes it is um
all right so dawn uh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally i was born
in escondido
raised in vista by san diego yeah in san
diego north county san diego
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents when you were a kid
uh my dad caught life sentences when i
was three my mom been missing since i
was about you know
life yeah you were three
yeah i was three what was what did you
do
he killed i guess that's what he did
yeah that'll do it
yeah and what was mom my mom she pretty
much
told her life i guess she disappeared
and then
my family on my mom's side raised me and
my sister
so your mom disappeared yeah at what age
you you were
about 11 it was official you never saw
her again
no wow
and how would you describe your
childhood um
good for when it was good i mean um
we went to like disneyland every year we
went and we did all kinds of different
things growing up i guess that's what
they did to keep us
not wanting to go anywhere else but it
had his dysfunction
like my uncle molested me and whatnot
you know what age
uh elementary school yeah so when it
came out
um my aunt pushed me away and i
started running the streets and i was
about 14 years old i said and started
establishing more
establishing more relationships around
in the neighborhood and stuff like that
you know
wow yeah how far did you in school
i dropped out in sixth grade but my dad
was like so you want to
live that lifestyle because i was in and
out a lot he said when you go in you hit
the books so i did i got tutored on the
side and
blessed with a lot of credit so by 95 i
graduated with a high school diploma a
ged
high school diploma yeah i earned a lot
of credits i see
yeah getting uh two or two on the side
but it was hard and uh drugs came into
the picture for you at what age
about 11 11. yeah i started drinking and
smoking
weed and stuff by 13 i started
experimenting more heavy drugs and stuff
like that
and do you have kids yeah they're with
my family
how many kids you have six six kids
two grandkids oh wow yeah
so what are your drugs today uh harold
and crystal herriman and crystal
and uh how are you supporting yourself
now
either working doing side jobs um
and then um cleaning houses
and like doing offices and stuff like
that um
usually whatever i can to get money
just wrestling yeah general hustling
yeah
generally yeah every day does that
include sex work sometimes
yeah sometimes yeah yeah i find like
pretty much almost every female i talk
to ah i could imagine
some of the guys too you know the guys
too i just i just did two interviews
with guys that are doing it
really yeah wow interesting yeah
it seems to be a big fad right now well
it's very
you can make money with it so yeah it's
the easy money maker
yep and where do you stay now um
i was staying with um in-laws
but um i picked up a gambling habit
and then they started tripping when the
kobe came out
so i kind of just stepped back and i was
being homeless
and just unsteady for the last few
months and stuff
how tell me about your gambling habit
go to the casino i'll win i'll put it
back in i'll put in i'll lose
everything you know it's it varies how
much you're gambling how much you get
winning or losing a day
during the day a good day a good couple
thousand
uh bad day um it depends on
how much i put into it but you can go
up to from a couple hundred to a
thousand yeah so
you're winning or losing overall either
way yeah because you're putting it back
in you're going in for the kill you're
trying
to you're getting you're trying to get
your money yeah you're trying to get
money you know
especially if you're in there to play
the right way i learned that gradually
you know yeah yeah
and the the gambling thing is
is something you're controlling or is it
kind of out of control
it got really out of control i'm
controlling it now
i'm controlling it now i'm a lot more
aware of the relationships that is just
it's ruined um the time consumed
um the money the effort the
everything i don't even care if i would
stay stranded i see stronger one time
for a month at the casino
yeah and
still my daughter one of my daughters
she would laugh because we check up on
each other and stuff
but she's like mom you will struggle and
you will still
find a way to get through or still
like you manage to have a good time you
know and
i guess for what it's worth and when
it's bad it
it gets bad but i still have to maintain
it like i have to hold my composure
through everything you know it's like
life's a [ __ ] sometimes you know excuse
my language
what emotions do you deal with do you
get depressed or angry or
anxious or depressed anxiety
um
stress confusion
um i think those ones are the main ones
yeah is there shame
and oh yeah shame definitely you're not
with your kids and you're gambling and
drugs everything yeah all that stuff
must
cause shame right what's been the lowest
point of your life
the lowest point losing um
my kids losing everything um having to
start over
yeah what's been the best best part of
your life um
[Music]
having it all all of them i think
being stable and the like family
relationship whereas me
the baby's father the kids
the place the car you know we're just
really living content
happy just really chilling and stuff but
it sounds nice
decisions at the end of the day are what
ruin everything what do you think throws
a wrench in that
the lifestyle you know whether if he's
smelling dope or you know i mean and
getting caught
or you know i'm saying those were the
main things that really like
put things in its toll you know yeah
that's the way i see it
do you think there's something in your
childhood that kind of set you on that
path or is it just
yeah i think exactly such a major role
even though some people might not want
to admit it
like i think it does like what the the
sexual abuse
yeah i think that and not only that just
like um
not having really a adult figure to look
up to or somebody to guide me the right
way
or what not you know yeah
yeah i mean i've been guided by some
pretty good people you know like
but i say from the best and the worst of
them you know
do you think you're uh self-destructive
did you call yourself yes i can't be i
had an epiphany one day and i realized
that
a lot of things that i shouldn't be
going through
um i had a friend just ring my ass
recently
and he was like you struggle because you
want to struggle
everything's sitting at the tip of your
fingers and you don't even realize it
and i'm just like
that alone right there was a reality
check too again
you know and that was just recently yeah
do you do you see a similarity between
the gambling
[Music]
issue you have and the drug addiction
yeah they're like some there's no they
can't
yeah because it's all an addiction yeah
all of it
yeah there's just different flavors of
the same yes
even whether it's sex or just like
whatever it could be anything
all of it is like addicting
yeah and even though common sense tells
you that this is destructive and bad for
you
you're drawn to it i'm like whoa okay
and then i'll go and
run ahead like head-on collision type
style you know
right um
you have uh you've been in love before
in love
have you been in love before i think so
yeah
yeah that was nice
life is kind life love is cruel i don't
know
um done all those things yes
and it's weird because once i hit 30
like all the guys i got with after that
not that it was like a bunch but i'm
saying like everything that's magnetized
to me
they're younger and so my last
relationship which was as long as he was
10 years younger and
it's been difficult because he's very
jealous controlling
deals with his own insecurities i'm sure
as well but
love and things to be taught in a
relationship
i learned it from him as well yeah yeah
it had his pros and cons yeah how old
are you
42 42. what do you worry about
worry about
money my thing is like
i feel like i'm at an age where if i
were to get a good amount
i see myself wanting to get like a night
a house maybe a few acres
maybe build on it or something you know
like already and stuff like that
when you were a young girl did you have
dreams of living a different life than
this
oh yeah who would have thought you know
yeah who'd have thought and even though
i knew at some point
i never would have thought it would have
even brought me here just get real i
would have never in my right mind
thought
i would even thought to even step foot
i gracefully walked in not even
realizing that's what i was stepping
into
i just a few minutes ago it was like
i've been walking through scare raw
and like this whole time like in
straight dits
[Laughter]
it was pretty sad out here man
yeah it's really it's humanity it's yeah
god bless you too what you're doing like
that's pretty cool
i think i think there's lessons here for
all of us right yeah
i know when i go home when i go back
home it won't be something i would want
to repeat
you know and i tell myself all the time
and god always says something for my ass
i swear to god
and it's all good though you know it's
like
wow but i know at the same time i need
to make some
other better decisions you know yeah do
you see yourself getting out of this
situation yeah yeah i started college
like a few years like
the year before i was in sober living
and i was uh
working full-time and whatnot and then
um
while doing all these things even in
silver living the
the one that ran the house around the
houses
they always had something for me like
and whether if they got proven wrong in
the end
um i just finally took a step back
and then i got laid off from a job
and then uh it kind of threw me in a
funk that's what took me back
you know did you find yourself learning
from your mistakes or just repeating
them over and over again
learning every time i think once i go
back and i'm thinking about maybe going
back to school
um
i'm not going back i don't want to go
back
i've been considering stopping till
but there's a new shop that they haven't
want to check out maybe
not the viver todd it's another one to
that helps you detox i guess
yeah what's what's what has meaning for
you
in your life with what's life my
children
my family my sister my brother
my nieces my nephews family yeah at the
end of the day
friends i have i'm grateful for
and all those dues
to all in all my sister even reminds me
of how blessed i am
and how things have they could
considerably be worse you know
sure you seem happy really yeah thank
you
are you happy at some point in saying
that yeah at some point i am because
it's like
through it all like everybody's been
there for me a lot of people been there
for me
and for me to end up out here like i
lost my phone and it's just hard
you know i haven't touched base with
nobody i haven't told nobody where i'm
at
don't nobody has a slightest clue that
i'm on skid row
it's crazy what's the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
not to trust a lot of people you know
and um even burned huh have you been
burned
oh yeah dude i got burned last night
even
for a coach person i wanted to sell you
know yeah i got robbed this morning
yeah i know dude who's dying it's like
that's so [ __ ] up i'm sorry to hear
that somebody that i've helped out but
but apparently not enough so somebody
you helped out before
yeah somebody i interviewed oh my god do
they
yeah the other people i'm interviewing
very often are they come from a
very a rough background study
yeah yeah we uh we don't have nobody at
the end of the day
so i'm grateful for my family that we we
stick together and
the family's good huh your family
supportive of you
a lot of them aren't everybody just
scattered you know pretty much
everybody wants to check up and act like
they're concerned and they ask my sister
and whatnot but
i don't know what to give a [ __ ] i don't
think you know
except for my immediates and you know
it's crazy and if they do they don't
they don't want to show it you know but
like i'm thankful for my kids and my
sister and my brother
my brother's changed a lot too though so
i guess he asked recently to my sister
so what's up with dawn
and her and her madness you know like
what kind of [ __ ] she into these days
you know so
oh wait till i get a load of this one
too
[Laughter]
all right dawn well thank you so much
for sharing your story oh my god thank
you
thank you best of luck out here thanks
get out as soon as you can
hi i know i know with this money i plan
on going home
good for you yes
i can go get a ticket